Jason told me he used to put his camera
you know his phone and a little baggie
and jerk off in the shower I guess he
has a thing about jerking off in the
shower oh so he's watching it through
the bag yeah no I mean I haven't done in
a while but yeah same thing you know
that Jason got caught by his wife he was
in bed with the iPad and a box of
tissues and he fell asleep so she I was
naked on the bed with lesbian porn
playing on my iPad she didn't just leave
the [ __ ] house true you use VR porn
now like you wear a headset oh yeah Oh
er porn what's that virtual reality
points we put the goggles on man you
look down and you have the porn star
stick down there and then you got this
woman climbing all over you and she
whispering in your ears and she's it's
very like your mind just [ __ ] really
goes there very but don't you need to be
aware of your outside surroundings so
you don't get caught oh I haven't done
it since we've been home with Kovac
because you need to make sure that you
got like eight hours because when you
have the headset on and the headphones
on the whole outside world disappears so
like literally like 20 people can walk
in the room and I'd have no idea so what
did you tell your wife you were getting
those goggles for Star Wars games
walking me nude with a big apparatus on
my nose yeah talking back to the girl
I'm like you like some again
weirdo let me see the gear do you have
it there I can't see oh my god you look
like one of the x-men like one of those
ants look at that thing I might come
over to your place when this whole thing
is over and try out those headphones and
it's not quite as great as Jason makes
it out to be cuz you're like yeah I'm a
[ __ ] loser wearing head goggles right
now and the video is is pretty grainy
still it's not perfect really well you
were drunk and Chris and I were touching
your knees the entire time I think Chris
bloomin